Paul Manon et Steven avait entre 24 et
25 ans
Steven était un jeune père de famille
l'accompagne de Paul était enceinte de
son premier enfant pour plus avoir une
pensée pour ces trois jeunes policiers
dont la vie était devant eux qui faisait
leur métier tranquillement avec
professionnalisme j'ai une pensée
évidemment pour cet enfant qui va avoir
un an qui va pas connaître son père pour
cette femme qui est enceinte et qui va
pas pouvoir présenter son futur enfant à
son papa hier matin l'équipage de police
se rendait à l'hôpital de Lille pour
faire examiner une jeune fille de 16 ans
qui disait avoir été agressée plus tôt
il circulait GIROFARD allumé en face une
voiture roule dans ta vie value en sens
inverse les premiers résultats sont
tombés le conducteur de l'Alfa Romeo
présente un taux d'alcool dans le sang
de 2,08 G
et il est par ailleurs positif au
cannabis 1,2 milliards d'euros c'est
notre chiffre du jour et c'est le
montant record de l'amende infligée par
l'Europe à méta la maison mère de
Facebook le géant américain également en
propriétaire d'Instagram et de WhatsApp
est condamné pour avoir transféré des
données d'utilisateur vers les
États-Unis en violation des règles
européennes méta compte faire appel
revoilà donc Riri Fifi et Loulou les
casseurs du gaullisme finissant ou les
Pieds Nickelés c'est selon je dis je
suis taquin parce que la dernière fois
qu'on a vu ces trois là nous dire vous
allez voir ce que vous allez voir ben on
a rien vu justement ou plutôt aussi une
sacrée pétaudière vous vous souvenez
alors que propose Riri Fifi et Loulou
dans cette interview un repompage en
règle du programme de Marine Le Pen
regardez on a fait une animation avec le
logo du RN des que c'est très inspiré
c'est un arsenal de mesure
rétablissement du seuil du délit de
séjour qui en destin de la double peine
durcissement du regroupement familial
des conditions d'accès à l'aide à l'aide
vous savez médical d'État bref tout ça
ça peut se et on peut trouver des
compromis mais quand ils nous dis cette
à prendre ou à laisser le compromis
devient plus difficile nous allons voir
la plupart des mesures ont déjà été
proposées par le parti d'extrême droite
le vocabulaire aussi et le même Bruno
Retailleau veut couper les pompes
aspirantes à savoir les aides sociales
pour les migrants je leur demande
surtout de royalties à Marine Le Pen là
il faut vraiment payer droit d'auteur
parce que c'est incroyable c'est un
copier-coller quasi mot pour mot des
propositions de Marine Le Pen la droite
propose de modifier la Constitution en
fait elle veut réaffirmer la
souveraineté de la France et ainsi
pouvoir déroger au droit européen au
droit international en matière
d'immigration non la première chose que
j'ai dit à la première ministre c'est
qu'il y aura pas de page de tournée
c'est que le sujet retraite est encore
d'actualité je vous rappelle qu'il y a
une proposition de loi du groupe Lyot
pour le 8 juin la proposition de loi qui
sera examinée par l'Assemblée au début
du mois de juin porté par le groupe
piote et non seulement inconstitutionnel
puisqu'elle ne respecte pas l'article 40
en créant une charge une dépense en tout
cas une moindre recettes à hauteur de 15
milliards d'euros par an et par ailleurs
cette proposition de loi elle a été
jugée recevable elle a été enregistré
par le Bureau de l'Assemblée nationale
et nous verrons ensuite comment les
choses se passent il faut que le
congouvernement comprenne une chose s'il
veut faire des mesurettes c'est sans
nous s'il veut faire juste quelques
ajustements c'est sans nous tout le
monde sait qu'elle n'a aucune chance
d'aboutir non seulement parce qu'elle a
un constitutionnel mais parce que le
Sénat ne la votera certainement jamais
le gouvernement a dû se justifier après
une polémique sur l'évaluation du taux
d'absentéisme constaté lors de l'Aïd
el-Fitr la fin de la fête de fin du
ramadan dans un vacarme de tôle les
pelleteuses se sont mises au travail au
petit matin dans le nord de l'île talus
2 est un des plus grands bidons villes
de Mayotte 162 cases qui vont être
démolies dans la semaine dans l'académie
de Toulouse des policiers avaient
demandé à des chefs d'établissement de
leur communiquer le nombre d'absents à
l'occasion de la fête de la rupture du
jeûne du mois de Ramadan 86 familles
habitaient ici la moitié a été relogée
dans des appartements ou maison en dur
plus agréable mais désormais il faut
payer un loyer aux États-Unis un
conseiller municipal républicain de
redisland se retrouve dans la tourmente
après avoir été contrôlé par les forces
de l'ordre juste après avoir consommé du
crack et français et les étrangers en
situation régulière sont relogées les
illégaux sont expulsés les navettes vers
les Comores ont repris la semaine
dernière après trois semaines
d'interruption on y voit Matthew raylie
41 ans dans un état second plus
qu'inquiétant
des images qui alimentent la polémique
dans un pays où la consommation
d'opioïdes ne cesse d'augmenter